[Music]
in subway seizure news submitted by
laminated dick what laminated why would
you do a permanent condom I guess that's
what it is
a subway writer faked a seizure to scare
off a mugger oh that's actually pretty
[ __ ] awesome possum you should call
it awesome possum news god that's like a
guy should just come on and create the
title yeah can't do that very [ __ ]
funny [ __ ] who the [ __ ] told us that
story where they pretended to be deaf
was that steep video girl yeah oh yeah
from a panhandler a panhandler and he's
you think I need to utilize [ __ ] like
that more like there was that one girl
who pretended she didn't like she was
deaf and like sign language to a guy
they kept on trying dancing her in the
club and that's a oh [ __ ] or like never
stopped me I'm cool alright I learned
recently I don't know why I never did
this before but when telemarketers call
you just [ __ ] speaking another
language I showed on that will you just
leave me the [ __ ] alone are you just
hanging up on him yeah but that feeling
that just makes them call back I just
don't pick up phone calls I do because I
get so curious like who loses what I get
tired I never you carry when it starts
ringing and I see a number I get tired
cuz just opening up like listening to
them and going hello and thinking and
like talking on party lines back in the
day that's different you guys not party
yeah like group chat all that stuff I
mean that's different when you're in
junior high and you have nothing to do
but homework mmm and I don't even do
homework so I rather hear about like
so-and-so's boyfriend girlfriend
whatever and what party they went to and
[ __ ] like that but now it's like I know
it's gonna be some haunting call it's
gonna be about some kind of Aldous bill
or like this being or business or like
what if you
one a million dollars and you'll never
know that's how I think that they're
trying to arrest me
no I doubt it I've seen that [ __ ] before
I thought that I [ __ ] then why do you
answer your phone
cuz I get so curious cuz if you're if
you were calling me to tell me some
funny [ __ ] that Isaac did I but I can't
wait to listen to this [ __ ] how would
you know you're not a mind reader huh
but I don't get those calls that's why
I'm saying I don't get conditioned you
calls give all the calls I get is like
business or tasks so that's why I'm like
ah the other the other night with all
like the prank calls and stuff I I did
get a call from a number I didn't know
but totally forgot that I set up a phone
call meeting with someone else picked up
hello hey genius Bebo like hey so you
talked on the phone
I preferred texting or email I do prefer
texting but when it comes to business
and people are just so adamant like I'll
tell him I just have to me like well
there's a lot to discuss I'd rather [ __ ]
okay fine and it's usually on speaker
and I'm playing video games I'm even
paying attention like half the time and
pretty bad I wish people could just read
my mind no right yeah like I wish I
could just read emails instead of
replying I just go cool or like I look
someone texts me why and they just like
well then if that was the case then you
can't fake a seizure to get out of
getting mugged no cuz I'll read my mind
like get away from me I spit in your
mouth and I have eight years of [ __ ]
gotcha Bart that's his telepathic sound
that should be my voicemail I'm tired
[Laughter]
okay oh this is covering me yeah so this
woman her name is Julie she was on the
BART Bay Area Transit yeah it's like a
starburst she's go up in transit it's
like a San Francisco Bay Area like in
Daly City
she was a filipinos that's where they're
from yeah it's a lot of money yeah so
she was handed a note that said there
are two guns pointed at you now if you
want to live hand back your wallet plus
phone now plus do not turn around and be
discreet do not turn around until after
you have left the Civic Center plus you
will live I mean and that's when you
turn around and you are sunglasses and
you just she says she thought that if
she fakes a seizure or fake like she's
passing out like as a reaction from the
note then they can't really do anything
and people will come for the help
exactly so that's Big Mac we would have
stole spa I would have never thought of
that I would have just [ __ ] I want to
pass my wallet here give to that guy
over there but he has no guns yeah who's
like a random guy so as soon as she
started to pretend like to have this
seizure that's when people started you
know looking over and asking if she was
okay and then the suspect just left oh
he got away so smart they should be
cameras in those trains I would have I
would have I would have made it oh I
want a hand with the wallet to the guy
next to him so like here you go sir and
your sensation so they are saying that
they did pull the surveillance footage
and the employees are currently
reviewing it why are they such shitty
CCTV footage like Oh chop and [ __ ] like
why can't we have a nice 4k video oh she
cute victims and big ass eyes she's cute
she's trying to pursue her modeling
career and this is one of those stories
to get her famous why she's not even
like a nurse's
she's not even trying to be she said it
all she robbed by a girl
very good handwrite like that's cute
girl handwriting oh she didn't mention
that it did look like it was a woman
yeah that's that's a girl's handwriting
right there
that's a beautiful Jean why is it so
nice it's not even threatening yeah
because now like the way I read it is
way different is there are two guns
now if you want to live like hand back
your wallet and phone now and do not
turn around and be discreet do not turn
around after you have left Civic Center
and you will live okay heart
bethenny that sounds like they're scared
of robbing her yeah cuz if I saw this
note I'm like dude no bold criminal
would do this someone who's afraid would
do it maybe that's how she was like she
had time to think yes that's probably
like there's a gun here someone has a
gun and it'll be like really and it'll
get scared yeah so like the person that
she described to the police is an older
white woman with a suitcase
what Wow old white woman it's crazy yeah
woman yeah she said that she wouldn't
press charges if the person was caught
because she wasn't actually robbed but
so she'll let her do it again attempted
robbery though I would press charges to
the full effect punish me in the face
and tried to rob me but he didn't get
anything so I won't press charges stupid
that's what kind of logic is that no
getting close to the face we're gonna do
it again
hi Bethenny I feel like if I'm ever in
the situation for sure that's gonna be
the first thing I think about no but
you're you're in a train like I'd feel
safe in a train well they're mentioning
there was 15 other people in the car and
I'm still full net so you don't know
could become a hostage hostage situation
but at least yeah they're stuck in that
train so there's no [ __ ] way you're
getting out there was this um really
shady looking guy and um we were taking
a train in France it was me Jess ant and
Christina and then this is right after
Christina got perved out by this guy and
he was ya know someone else but this guy
was like yelling
like as he was walking up and down to
train like a crazy you know crackhead or
something and he was just saying stuff
and then he was walking up and down and
then when he came close
Jess wasn't next like in the hall Aaron
Paul sighed sights so I went in front
and I was like putting my stuff down I'm
like this guy's [ __ ] loose like and
then he got close but then I was looking
at everybody in the Train and I was like
well if the locals don't pay attention
maybe I shouldn't be so worried but in
LA like you have a screaming crazy
homeless guy you don't know like you'll
just punch people randomly or he'll you
know you just don't know unpredictable
stuff right but then when I looked at
the locals and they're just like
ignoring him I'm thinking what if he's
just saying like I'm poor I'm hungry I
need money in a stomach you know what I
mean like that's [ __ ] up no but it
just seemed aggressive like who's saying
it really loud and I was like [ __ ] is he
yelling at people for there's like you
get how to get conditioned out here -
cuz I was I was with Khalif and we were
getting a [ __ ] motto got me you know
right in front of there yeah dude came
up he was just like a regular so done
place alright it's just a regular dude
coming up to me but I'm so conditioned
to people coming up to me and asking me
for money and he just coming because hey
how you doing fellas I was like what's
up he was like whoa huh he was just
telling us that there was like a charity
donation down oh and I was like dude
Tiffany and I went to eat the other day
and we were sitting outside and this
lady she didn't look well her teeth was
missing if she had a her clothes my
gentleman but her clothes were like well
fitted nice and clean she comes up she's
like I'm so hungry can you buy us some
food if he's like oh I have some
leftover he's here and she's like what
is it you know and then it looked like
it's food and then she's like but what
is it and I'm like just eat it and then
that's when I was like it's a grilled
cheese and then she goes oh I don't want
to mess it up I'm like
it's fine I'm like [ __ ] you wanted to
eat something I wanted money I was
insulted
yeah order something else you probably
wanted something fresh I want [ __ ]
speakers you wanted like the most
expensive thing in the money because
we're in Beverly Hills yeah as a
[ __ ]
salty about if like the rest of daily
right like you're so [ __ ] hungry but
you don't want like I don't want it like
shift-key most of the most bullsh excuse
I don't want to mess it up food if you
if you go to if you guys have ever
volunteered in places in LA the people
will tell you to essentially like staff
neighbors especially the food being they
tell you like food is available it's not
whether they're hungry or not yeah do
what they want money for specific things
so most of the time if they do want food
they want specific food there's not the
fact that they can't get food you know
or maybe in LA anyways yeah what if her
game was like oh yeah can you buy me
some food and then we'd be like yeah for
sure what do you want we'll give her
them and you should be like oh I kind of
want this thing it cost this much can I
just have the money maybe that's what
she got upset
maybe she's gluten free like I'll buy
the food look at that's what it is
that's why I was just saying here like
they had just packaged the land I don't
even touch do it one by eight yeah
because it was like half of a sandwich I
just ate the other half I don't even
touch that and I'll just like hear but
sometimes they don't want us uh what do
you call it like they even if you give
them food right they have money you
don't want to spend the money on food
because they want to use it for alcohol
or something we never crack or what I
like or yeah yeah but there's the honest
ones that just they need it they need
socks or toothbrush or whatever and you
know yeah most likely if you're hungry
too you know somebody says like yo can
you get me first like cool that want a
Subway sandwich the poem say yes if
they're hungry I don't need anything
yeah just look at her she's not like
homeless her clothing fit too well it
looked too new [ __ ] how do you do
folks thank you so much for watching
don't forget to subscribe to stay up on
their most recent upload and any other
cool content that we put up there and
hit the subscribe button for the last
video click up here
[Music]